so recently Nike decided to come out
with this just do it Atwood colin
kaepernick n everybody flipped out
however following day online sales up 31
percent
according to apex marketing all the
exposure Nike got on social media TV
radio made them a hundred and sixty
three and a half million dollars was it
a right move or was it a bad move you
know so many people start asking about
Kaepernick and I said you know what I
don't know if I want to make a video
about this or not but you know what let
me just make the video because a lot of
the entrepreneurs that follow value
taming their kana in this position right
now saying I feel like the market's
going to this corporate social
responsibility everybody needs to talk
about it
some stateö did they said Millennials
prefer doing business with corporations
seventy-one percent of them like when
the company talks about what they stand
for socially it's almost like you're in
dinner and you have the one rule never
talk about politics and dinner starts on
Thanksgiving what do you think about
Trump what do you think about Bernie I
don't think they're doing outdone in
Europe I really want to share my
opinions should I not or should I just
think quiet so I maintain a relationship
with my family I don't want to lose
customers what if my customers hate me
I'm gonna give you all the perspectives
of whether you should cover politics
today or not some of him you gonna like
some of them you're not gonna like but
I'm just gonna give it you the way it is
number one so the first thing you ought
to be thinking about is whether you're
public or a small business owner now
somebody may say Pat who cares if I'm
public or a small business owner big
difference here's why a private company
can say whatever they want to say this
is my business I'm private this is what
I stand for it's a family-owned business
we stand for this we stand for that and
my employees are my sales people know
about it and my customers DOM okay with
that maybe on the public side if a CEO
gets up and he smokes weed on a podcast
hypothetically and the stock drops the
following week by 10% maybe that wasn't
the best decision he ought to be free to
be able to do it when it's a publicly
traded company which means shares are
tied to investors who are putting money
into the CEO making the right decisions
so you may say so Patrick are you
telling me as a small business owner I
should talk about it it's not what I'm
telling you what i am telling you is a
bigger company can afford a risk a lot
more than a small company can
still doesn't mean shouldn't talk about
the things you stand for but there is a
risk for number two here's the other
thing to keep on mind times have changed
we're not talking about the 60 seventies
today or 80s in 1984 Michael Jordan when
they asked him they said hey so are you
Republican or Democrat he says listen my
customers are both Democrats and
Republicans why would I say anything by
myself politically they're by my shoes I
won both of them right we're in today
LeBron James gets up on Twitter and says
hey chump hey you know you're such a bum
he never really said he was gonna come
in the first place and he gets six
hundred thousand retweets whatever the
number was when he did that and he's
looked at as what a social leader you
couldn't do that back in the days back
in the days in 1994 before there was
Steph Curry there was Chris Jackson this
guy will hit three pointers with his
eyes closed and then one day he came on
and said I'm a Muslim and when we would
do the national anthem he would hold his
hands out like this he wouldn't put his
hand on his heart but he wouldn't an
interview with woman anybody oh my gosh
look what this guys doing David Starr
possibly the greatest Commission on the
NBA ever had that was a conflict two
years later his career is over today
Colin Kaepernick comes out he does what
he does he takes a kneel next thing you
know he gets kicked out at the NFL and I
believe in my opinion my opinion this
wasn't the NFL owners fault this wasn't
anybody's fault the biggest fault for me
is Roger Goodell because he didn't
address the issue right off the bat
because he was worried about renewing
his two hundred million dollar five-year
contract with his private jet that he
wanted what's the point
Shareef abdur-rahim doesn't get a
contract with Nike because it was about
being safe no social media Colin
Kaepernick signs a multi multi-million
dollar contract and comes out and says
just do it number three it has a lot to
do when you share your opinions on what
side of the aisle the media is in
meaning if the media is on the left 80%
you may not want to go against liberals
and Democrats because they're gonna
attack you all out if it's on the right
you may not want to go against the right
because they're gonna attack you all out
today media favors Democrats which means
anybody like LeBron that comes out and
says something about Trump he's seen as
a social leader if anybody comes out and
says anything about Obama hi there's a
lot of different words you can use for
some other like that right if he says
anything about Obama because media is
gonna take the Democrats
so you also have to keep that part in
mind when you're coming out knowing who
your enemy is going to be number four
here's the other part to be thinking
about today with social media almost
everybody is naked today what do I mean
by this you post anything in social
media I could go on 20 different posts
that you've had and pretty much figure
out whether you're conservative whether
you're a Democrat whether you're
Republican whether you're not so it's
pretty much not hard to figure those
things out when I'm talking about social
issues like corporate social
responsibility is you coming out and
saying I don't agree with what Trump did
with banning refugees coming here and he
said this and hey we are gonna hire
10,000 refugees you know our name is
Starbucks and we're gonna do this that's
what we're talking about but as far as
political if you get to a point where
you're so worried about having everybody
find out what you really are then you're
gonna have a big problem because you're
not being yourself you're not gonna
enjoy building a business
so regardless everyone's pretty much
gonna have an idea which way you lean
politically number five so listen any
time it comes down to making decisions
like this the big mistake that a lot of
people make is when they come out
without thinking about what they support
hey everybody saying Trump sucks let me
just come out and say it everybody says
Obama this everyone so you're not really
saying what you're thinking about
because it's not thought-out that's when
we make the mistake you have to sit back
and talk to yourself your board some
councils and say here's what I feel
about this I want to come out talk to
the attorneys talk to advisers knowing
what the worst case scenario is because
the worst case scenario you gotta know
here's what could happen you could come
out and take a big hit for it people
hate you for it there's a bunch of
negative articles written about you and
it could lead to you actually going out
of business that is actually a
possibility that you have to keep in
mind that is the worst case scenario
having said that the best case scenario
is the following you come out and you
stand and you tell your position here's
where I stand
here's what I disagree with here's what
I agree with and moving forward we're
going to focus on X Y Z and when you do
that it doesn't mean you won't get
backlash you will but the best case
scenario is all of a sudden you have a
low Joe Royle customers believers true
believers all around the nation possibly
all around the world now I want to buy
your product because they know what you
stand for
number six so you know the big question
people ask nowadays or should I build my
own brand and my company's brand which
one should I build and the idea is what
in today's world people want you to
build both brands because you have the
business brand and you have your brand
so let's talk about your brand what is
really behind your brand is it just
today's a great day to drink coffee I
woke up today and I'm a LeBron James fan
you know I like you know juice I like my
food this way it's not just about what
kind of food you like take a bunch of
selfies what do you really think about
what are your beliefs that's the brand I
mean value Timmy you're gonna get a
chance to find out what I believe in
some of you guys don't like it I don't
like the fact that this guy's all about
capitalism and entrepreneurship but
that's where I'm at that's what I
believe in that's your personal brand
that's your business brand so what's the
point here the risk today you take is
two risks one risk is the risk of you
coming out and everybody says I can't
stand the fact that this guy believes in
XYZ we know it's the bigger risk that
you come out and nobody thinks about you
and you become irrelevant and number
seven here's the other thing to be
thinking about this isn't something you
can wig and come out and say here's what
we think about this I mean Nike do you
think Nike just came out one day after
Kaepernick won through what he went
through and then they made the video
look how long it took before they did
the commercial it wasn't a month after
he was going through his kneeling the
first time he did it took a while you
don't think they had focus-group people
sitting some we should do we shouldn't
do it you don't think they went through
the advisors you don't think Nike sat
down and asked themselves who their
ideal customers are that buys shoes from
them so when people came out and said I
will never buy a Nike ever again said a
62 year old man that hasn't bought a
Nike for 20 years and all the other
people that buy Nikes went about more
Nikes that's why they went up now in the
complete opposite side Pepsi sees black
lives matter and we're gonna capitalize
on this let's go get Kendall Jenner who
is so connected to middle America and
low income right I mean she is fully
connected to it and they do this
commercial with kendall Jenner who takes
her wig off in the commercial they
probably didn't even know they did this
she throws the wake to an
african-american girl which makes zero
sense for her doing that and walks out
and gives a Pepsi to the cop while the
other girl is shooting the camera saying
don't shoot wait to drink in
everybody's happy and by the way on top
of everything else that Pepsi did they
lost a hundred million dollars of media
pi gone so now you may be watching the
same pad I don't really understand what
you're saying at this point are you
saying for me to do it or not to do it
here's what I'm trying to tell you Nike
unlike Pepsi knew in advance when they
execute this commercial who's not gonna
be happy with them and they're okay with
that they were fully aware of it they
knew people were gonna say I'll never
buy Nike ever again they know it and
they're okay losing that but they also
knew on the other hand the people that
are buying from them are gonna double
down and become true believers
while Pepsi on the other hand came out
and said here's what we stand for but
they completely missed it on execution
and they ended up offending people and
building the best commercial for
coca-cola instead of themselves look
some of you may be watching this right
now getting uncomfortable saying there's
no way in the world I want to get out
and talk about whether I like Trump or
not that's not what I'm saying there are
a lot of companies that for their
fulfillment of CSR corporate social
responsibility they may be contributing
to certain charities locally that matter
to them they may be doing certain things
for foster homes Breast Cancer Awareness
Month that has nothing to do with
politics your customer just want to know
what you stand for
by the way none of this stuff is going
away listen none of this stuff is going
away social media is not going away
everyone's gonna say their opinions so
if you don't say it no one's really
gonna know what you stand for by the way
made a video a couple weeks ago titled
why college is a scam you don't think we
got heat on it I have employees that
work women with college degrees they
watched it but we took a stand this is
our current system this is our current
belief system with college education if
you haven't watched it click on this
link to watch the video